Jeff is in Bakersfield California
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Jeff how
are you good Dave thank you for taking
my phone call sure what's up well I was
wondering if you could point me in the
right direction my wife and I are
currently on baby step number seven we
are current home that we live in is paid
for and our rental house is also paid
for but I think we're probably going to
be moving out of state here in the next
two years and so we're thinking about
maybe selling our rental house right now
and that's we're probably net about 170
175 for that home I guess my question is
what do we do with that money in the
short term I've always been told that
you know you don't want to put money
into mutual funds unless you have four
to five years timeframe of when you
actually need the money how do you feel
about that that's what I tell people as
well because a five-year mark not ninety
percent of five year periods have made
money only about sixty five percent of
the three year periods have made money
now the difference in your position is
you've done a really good job with your
money so you built a position of wealth
and so how much is in your 401k is in
your nest egg
we have probably six hundred and fifty
in our 401 yeah what's your homework
what's the equity in your home
what's your home worth the one I live in
is probably four hundred thousand okay
so you've got a net worth of over a
million dollars and and your household
income is north of six figures isn't it
yeah and how old are you 45 yeah almost
like I've done this before okay
well done I mean you hit that you hit
the marks man you're perfect well done
proud of you so what is your household
income 175 yeah okay
even better than I projected okay great
good for you so here's the thing when
you place 170 in a 1% money market for
two years
you will make nothing on it obviously
right if you made 10% on it for two
years in a mutual fund you would have
made thirty four thousand dollars okay
if the mutual fund went down ten percent
a year for two years which would be a
highly unusual two year two consecutive
years of that kind of loss in the market
like historically almost never happens
okay then you would lose thirty four
thousand dollars right none of these are
deal-breakers for you we have a million
dollar net worth you make understand if
I thought as long as thirty four
thousand dollars doesn't change your
life okay right so all of that said -
that puts you in a position more like I
would be and personally if I were going
to do this I'm probably going to put
some of that money in a mutual fund and
just because I can't stand for at all
sit there at 1 percent knowing that I'm
taking some risk but I'm probably not
taking risk that's going to completely
[ __ ] my financial plan okay you know
even if you let's say pray tell had the
worst possible scenario and you lost the
entire amount of money it does not ruin
your life it's they be horrible I'm not
suggesting you'd put it at risk at the
blackjack table okay I'm not suggesting
that I wouldn't do that but my point is
is that you are in a position to accept
some volatility on this one hundred
seventy thousand in order to try to get
a little bit red or a better rate of
return so if I'm in your shoes I'm
probably throwing like 70 in a money
market I'll probably pop in 100 and a
growth and income that's got a long
stable track record you know that that's
a boring type mutual fund super boring
in other words that kind of a thing and
I was trying to thumb through here and
look I've got one fund that I own that's
had a 12 point zero seven percent
average rate of return since 1934 but
here's the interesting part for our
discussion out of those 83 years 50
time's it was down the rest of time it
was up so that's called a growth and
income fund and that's a very stable
fund okay and so you know you could put
100 grand in that and you'll probably
make something you might lose a little
but you probably won't you know so I'm
doing that and even if you do you're
okay that's the way I would analyze it
is but if you call me up and you go I
have a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars to my name
this means whether I get to buy my next
home or not and I make sixty five
thousand dollars a year I would say
money market you can't say it you can't
stand the risk okay you see the
difference here but you could do either
one you can do either one either go
either way all in a money market or all
in a mutual fund because you can handle
the risk either way you're finding it's
just what's going to make you you know
what's gonna be fun
but the point is it's a ratio thing in
your overall net worth because you've
done such a great job well done
millionaire another every day
millionaire calling in here on the air